-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I appreciate it.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys,
the FDA just announced that
the U.S. has less
than two months to decide
whether Americans need
COVID booster shots this fall.
Yeah, but don't worry,
whatever they decide,
they promise
to roll out the new rules
in the most confusing way
possible.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Honestly, at this point,
how do we not have
Vaccine Prime?
[ Laughter ]
Well, earlier this week,
former President Obama
visited the White House.
Did you see that?
And everyone went nuts for him.
[ Laughter ]
Almost too crazy, yeah.
They just wouldn't
stop clapping.
[ Laughter ]
And Biden was like,
"Okay, we're good."
[ Laughter ]
But then he gave an address
that really boosted morale
and I think it's even
rubbing off on President Biden.
Listen to the speech
that Biden gave today. Listen.
-[ As Obama ]
Uh, okay, look,
there's too much, uh,
malarkey in Washington.
[ Laughter ]
I'm still committed to passing
[ Staccato ]
my Build Back Better plan.
Build Back Better.
You know, my mom used to, uh,
she'd sit me down.
She'd say, "Joey."
She'd say, "Don't take no rubber
pennies from nobody."
[ Laughter ]
But let me be clear, Jack.
I'd like to announce also
that I'm changing my name
from Joe Biden to just Obiden.
[ Laughter ]
I like that.
President Obiden.
Go, trains!
-Yeah, wow, go, trains.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Obiden.
-Obiden, like Obama.
-He wants to go by
President Obiden.
-Yeah.
-I like it, yeah.
That's good.
Guys, some entertainment news --
it was just announced
that Chip and Joanna Gaines'
Magnolia Network
is moving to HBO.
[ Oohing ]
-That should be great.
Now, they can finally show
all the profanity when a couple
fights over cabinet knobs.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of HBO, I read
that they're is planning
to create a Sherlock Holmes
TV Universe.
[ Oohs, smattering of applause ]
So, between this
and Chip and Joanna,
HBO really seems to be
into shows about ho(l)mes.
[ Laughter and slow clap ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ The Roots playing
mellow funk ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Ooh!
-Wow.
-Yeah.
And the Emmy goes to...
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this --
amid high oil price,
American Airlines is going
to use a bus service
as an alternative to some
[ Laughter ]
short connecting flights.
A bus, instead of a plane.
It's the equivalent of a waiter
saying, "We're out of Coke.
Is backwash okay?"
[ Laughter and ewws ]
On the bright side, at least
there won't be a security line,
since pretty much anything goes
on a bus.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's actually
a smart idea.
American Airlines is like,
"Oil prices are high,
but thank God
gas prices are low.
Bus it is!
No one reads the news."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Speaking of flights,
a former British Airways pilot
who lied about his
flying experience
has been sentenced
to a year in jail
after he pressed a button
"no qualified pilot would."
[ Laughter ]
Maybe I'm crazy, but if there's
a button in the cockpit
you should never press,
maybe don't put it on the plane,
you know?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Obama ]
Don't -- Don't
put it on the plane.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
I heard about a woman in Texas
who just finished running
her 1,000th marathon.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Even her FitBit was like,
"Okay, we get it."
[ Laughter ]
At this point,
her friends are like,
"Cheryl, what are you
running from?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show.